Markov processes can be very general
they can run in continuous or discrete
time can have a discrete or a continuous
state space in this class will restrict
ourselves to discrete time discrete
state Markov chains these are the
simplest cases and are the best to build
our intuition so the state space is
discrete here finite with M States and
time is discrete that is at any discrete
point in time the process is in one of
these M States and let's say here at a
given time s and again time is discrete
so think about the following process you
have someone hitting a drum indicating
that a transition occurs and what it
means is that the chain that was here
will then jump let's say to another
stage a at the next time so when the
Markov chain jumps it can jump on itself
or jump to another state like here or
here and then you know at time s plus 1
someone hit the drum and you jump again
and so on and so forth you can think of
a very active frog jumping from lilies
to lilies on the pond and following a
regular drum beat so what is left to
define are the various probability of
transitions such as the transition from
I to J and the notation is we're going
to use is P IJ which by definition is
that transition probability here
right so given that you are in state I
at time s what is the priority that you
end up in state J at time s plus one
notice that these transition
probabilities here P IJ are not function
of s so irrespective of what the term s
that we are talking about these
transition probabilities are the same so
this is what we mean by a time
homogeneous Markov chain in other words
these are valid for s equals 0 1 2 and
so and so forth so the defining feature
of a Markov chain is the Markov property
and the Markov property essentially says
that the past is not really important in
order to predict the future as long as
you know where you are now another way
of saying it is that if you look at the
probability of going next in stage a
even that you are now in state high and
that I give you in addition the anti
trajectory so I tell you that it was in
eysie row at that time and so and so
forth all the way up to time s minus 1
where it was in I s minus 1 so I give
you the anti trajectory of the chain up
to s and now I'm asking you what is the
priority that you're going to go to s
plus 1 the Markov property here simply
says that that probability here is again
p IJ so in other words all this
information here is of no use to compute
this probability now note that this
transition probabilities are really
probabilities in the following sense
right so you are in I and then at the
next time step you will definitely jump
with Priority One and where are you
going to jump or the pan but the
summation of all possibilities have to
sum up to one so from J equals 1 to n
has to be 1
so now that we have introduced the main
ingredients usually we are very
interested in knowing what a Markov
chain is going to do in the long run we
are interested in finding the
probability that the chain is in a state
J after n transitions given that it is
now in state I now because of the time
of more genius this is the same thing as
that in other words the current time
could be an any time s we just have to
add s here and again that is nothing
else than this property right so we are
interested in calculating our I G of n
for any n for N equals 1 this is nothing
else than our i G of 1 is the same as
these transition probabilities that we
have defined but for N greater than
equals to do what we have seen is the
introduction of a key recursion here and
this is what how you would be able to
calculate these probabilities now how
did we come up with this recursion well
it's based on a classical divide and
conquer and essentially the use of the
topology theorem essentially you have
the time step here this is the current
time s you are interested in what's
gonna happen at n plus s that means n
steps later here you are in state I you
are interested in knowing what is the
probability of being in state G at that
time and what you simply do is you look
at the step n plus n minus 1 just before
the last one and then you say well let
me do a divide and conquer this is K
here and I'm going to look at evaluating
that probability and then once I have
that I will simply multiply by this
transition here and what happened is
that this here is nothing else than this
calculation that we have here and that's
the same thing and here this is the
parity of one step transition and of
course we have conditioned on the fact
that we would be in a state K here but K
could be any of these states rights and
there are M of them and this is why we
son from K equals 1 to M so it's
actually this is how the scary question
has been put together and we have used
of course the
property in order to do that let's do
now a little bit of warm-up in terms of
calculation and apply these concepts